a florida police sergeant has been
charged with felony battery after being
caught on body cam video grabbing a
female police officer by the neck during
an arrest the footage shows sergeant
christopher police lunging for the
officer after she pulled him away from a
handcuffed suspect in a police cruiser
the female officer has not been publicly
named and police has been placed on
administrative leave we asked him for
comment and have not heard back manuel
bajorkas shows us how this confrontation
unfolded
all right i'm getting in by the time
sunrise police sergeant christopher
police arrives at the squad car the
suspect is handcuffed and in the vehicle
you want to play
you never get disrespected
remove your [ __ ] soul from your body
that is when another officer intervenes
and tugs at the sergeant's belt removing
the superior officer from the situation
but the sergeant lunges for the female
officer's neck his hands eventually
falling toward her shoulders
the disturbing body camera footage led
prosecutors in florida to charge police
last week with assault and battery on an
officer that should not have happened
sue rohr a former sheriff of kings
county washington is an expert in police
tactics we need to train our police
officers that no matter what you think
you're going to do
you have to override
your brain
and take steps
within days of george floyd's killing in
minneapolis many law enforcement
agencies reinforced active bystandership
training
three officers were convicted of federal
civil rights violations for failing to
intervene the female officer who has
been on the force for about three years
is being praised for her actions
which may not have come to light had the
officers complied with their sergeant's
commands just extremely proud of what
that officer did and i think the more we
celebrate her courage in that situation
the more we're going to see that kind of
behavior happening
police pleaded not guilty to all charges
if convicted he could end up behind bars
for up to 11 years he is currently on
administrative leave for cbs mornings
i'm manuel bojorquez in miami
i think she had it right when she said
we should applaud her coach also in the
in that moment she's still calling him
sir right she was actually trying to
help a fellow officer trying to help her
which she could see he was clearly
appeared to be a little out of control
because a guy was in the car she's
trying to help him and the other
officers are standing by and she
intervenes yeah
scary thing is
and and gil you might have said this
if he can do that to a fellow officer
what happens when he's arresting someone
if that's how he treats fellow officers
on camera on camera with other people
standing around imagine what he could do
to other people
he tells them to turn off yeah
at one point
we will continue to stay on top of that
story right about that